à l'origine du feu de forêt qui a ravagé
ce flanc de colline une simple étincelle
de tronçonneuses deux incendies
accidentels se sont déclarés à quelques
minutes d'intervalle ce mercredi dans le
haut jura
en tout 24 hectares de végétation sont
partis en fumée
ces incendies ont été favorisés par le
vent et la sécheresse mais aussi par une
végétation fragilisé on a aussi un
double peine puisque dans le secteur on
a eu des attaques de pyrale du buis
assez importante entre en 2018 on va
dire entre entre lons le saunier et
saint claude
on est sur le front et pendant la
défoliation parler fini le risque est
largement multiplier les incendies de
sortie d'hiver ne sont pas
exceptionnelles d'après les pompiers
ils se produisent avant que les arbres
n'est reconstituer leurs feuilles
le nombre de feux de végétation reste
constant dans le jura mais ils sont
aggravés par les conditions climatiques
et la végétation
on est aux alentours de 300 feu touchant
des espaces naturels par an sur le
territoire durant ce qui change c'est
qu'il évolue en terme d'intensité de
mobilité et donc au final de superficie
touchée mais aussi parfois de structures
aux douves rage un pacte et par c
incendie dans ce qui nous oblige à
renforcer nos moyens pour protéger les
personnes et les structures les pompiers
appellent à la vigilance de nouveaux
incendies pourraient se déclarer dans
les prochains jours et se préparent
aussi à des interventions en forêt
compliqué en cadets thé chaud et sec